let's let's go back to kyrie irving
because luke luke mentioned
kyrie irving refuses to get vaccinated
we have the story from insider.com the
nets are conceding he won't play in home
games in a stunning turn of events
man look there's there's there's big
there's hard falls and there's scary
falls there's a lot of people who say
you know i'm worried about
refusing this if i lose my job how do i
feed my kids and i completely understand
that yeah but but complying has got us
the point where now there's food
shortages now you've got someone like
kyrie irving who's worked hard his whole
life he's one of the best he's in the
nba and now he's going to now he's going
to potentially lose that
standing up for his beliefs there's
there's still a lot to lose a lot of
hard work people put in yeah he's
standing up for his principles and he's
putting up millions of dollars to and
he's making a stand here now he was
asked about this he says he doesn't
really want a lot of public media
attention on this he's trying to of
course work things out uh but new york
city mandates that
people get vaccinated if they want to
work there and he's working for the
brooklyn nets so this is this is
unfolding to a situation where it's not
just kyrie there's a lot of other nba
players that have been very articulate
that have been voicing their concerns
and have actually been talking about the
science and the the risk benefit
analysis here when it comes to healthy
athletic individuals risking themselves
to do a compliance procedure that might
have complications that might hurt them
and end their careers so there there's a
lot of uh you know things to weigh here
there's a lot of things to discuss here
but at least some of these nba guys are
starting the conversation and at least
they're making it an issue that can't be
avoided because when you have kyrie
irving one of the best players on that
team saying i'm not going to play home
games now because of this ridiculous
government mandate it puts it in your
face how over the top a lot of this is
we also have this story from timcats.com
former misfit singer michael graves
cancels los angeles concert over vaccine
mandate now this i have tremendous
respect for he says quote
i have made the decision to not perform
on october 13th in la at the whiskey a
go-go due to the city's vaccine mandate
that is being enforced as of october 7th
grave said in a statement provided to
tim cast i will not perform to a
segregated audience i will not
participate in any effort to pressure
anyone into undergoing an experimental
medical procedure to enter and dwell in
a building as a pro
prerequisite to see me perform
if i can't play for all of you i won't
play at all
i mean hey bro go on the street corner
and busk that'd be the coolest thing
ever oh yeah that would be a security
guard or something but giant middle
finger too to the venue and to all the
folks
tell everybody come outside watch for
free you know yeah i think that'd be
fantastic but this is this is this is
incredible i mean to be completely
honest there are a lot of people who say
a lot of words about i refuse you know
this vaccine mended is bad policy and
a lot of them don't actually put up they
they they don't put their money where
their mouth is they'll go and they'll
perform all the same at the vax mandate
places and like oh what's the big deal
you know if you really think if you
really oppose the vaccine mandates
then you would oppose them and not
be the tool by which these vaccine
mandates are implemented so these guys
kyrie irving i'm actually interested
because new york city is a performer
exemption
so so that's interesting like if if
graves were to play in new york city the
executive order says if you're
performing on stage you don't got to get
vaccinated yeah which is which which i
think is just makes no sense of course
it doesn't make sense but like you're
trying to make sense out of things that
are like you know designed to be
nonsensical but what's interesting i
know like a couple week or two ago i was
watching you and you're saying how hey
if you oppose the man and you know i
think caused a little bit of a stir on
twitter i was like yeah if you oppose
the mandate but you still you know get
the vaccine anyways then you don't
really oppose it and i get what you're
saying
or if you go along with the mandate i
said yeah if people if someone claims
that they oppose the vaccine mandate
right but then out of fear of losing
their job go and get the vaccine
mandated anyway they're not actually
opposing
they don't actually oppose it what i
mean to say is how is it opposition to
something that you're actively
participating in yeah you can dislike
something right opposing it so i i
people are looking at the word opposed
like i think it shouldn't be done versus
opposes and i'm actively standing up
against it yeah that's fair because
there's so many folks out there it's
like that you know they don't have you
know they're not professional athletes
they're not professional performers
where you know they're pulling down you
know 60 70 grand a year they got family
they're you know they don't have a ton
in savings and it's like they don't have
a lot of runway and it's like hey
no absolutely 100 i think that's why
it's good for folks like this to start
doing it's like okay maybe there's
something here and it's even better when
you're seeing an industry where it makes
them hurt where he's luck talking about
the pilots and also it's the flight
attendants i got a dm earlier it's like
hey don't forget about the flight
attendants because they make a lot less
money and also but they're in the exact
same boat and there's plenty of them too
and yeah that's a big one there's a lot
of southwest pilots yeah from what we're
hearing it's about half or or maybe just
under half are unvaccinated so that's
where when the pilots were talking to
him we know quite a few southwest pilots
you know being in the navy a lot of
pilots from the navy or marine corps go
right into working with southwest as an
example in this case
yeah and and that's what they're saying
is if they don't do this and maybe maybe
it's only 25 or 30 percent that just
refuse yeah that is that's still
significant it's a lot so what you think
already has their problems aside from
these most recent before all this so if
you think you have like a little less
than half of all the pilots are in back
so it's like the estimate right now and
let's say like half of those which is at
the other estimate half of those so yeah
20 25 maybe 30 percent at most are gonna
like lose their job that's a bad news
and also i gotta point out i gotta point
out this one gal who wrote to me her
name's crystal she sent me a dm she says
thank you for speaking about the
southwest airlines please don't forget
the thousands of flight attendants that
are facing termination as well my
20-plus years are being flushed down the
drain thank you for all you do well
let's think about what first of all we
feel you the logical conclusion to the
to these efforts right it'll be a lot
harder to fly
demand will still be there but the
prices will skyrocket there's
substantially less pilots there's less
flight attendants there's going to be
less availability yeah what do you get
hunger games yeah you're going to get
very wealthy elites you're going to get
the people who are willing to wear the
masks like uh was it hunger games that
had the avoxes we were talking about
that was hungry yeah so i guess this
wasn't in the movie yeah no it was part
of the book in the book they they the
rich the rich people in the capital have
servants whose tongues have been cut out
that's what it was yeah so it's so
interesting you mentioned the hunger
games because the way i see it kyrie
irving is really channeling what the
african-american community is feeling
right now and these celebrities saying
this is a counter to the hunger games
because they're saying no we're not
going to do this and not only that
normal people who are afraid to lose
their jobs they're not alone so seeing
all these captains do this and seeing
all these celebrities do this this has
got to be incredibly encouraging
at the same time hopefully if regular
people walk off their jobs say start
homesteading which i think would be good
i think that's fantastic just realize
we're going to live in a world where
only the wealthy elites are traveling
internationally the wealthy elites are
the only it's going to be like elysium
almost yeah everyone's going to be
living in like you know and and do these
people that these people want this i'd
imagine yeah and on a surf class but
also it's southwest because that's the
budget airline right
they're the ones that's hurting too like
the folks who can afford it can handle
it like they're flying either another
airline they're flying up front right
they're flying business for first class
or they're or someone would be flying
private they're flying you know any of
those like the budget airline is for
like the everyday folks hey it's a cheap
ticket gets me from where i got to go
taking the family to disney i got a bus
you know like that's what that is and
it's like it's going to hurt them the
most it's not hurting
you know the big boys yeah i don't know
if you guys ever heard of the term the
great reset
yeah but you know
a lot of globalists especially at the
world economic forum came together and
said that people are flying too much
people are consuming too much red meat
people are are enjoying life too much
and they need to be controlled and
regulated to the point where they have
no privacy owner nothing and they're
happier than ever so
when you look at what's happening now
especially with the larger economic
consequences the government has their
fingerprints all over it with helping
spur on a lot of troubling times that
are going to be coming very soon whether
it's lockdowns whether it's mandates
whether it's restrictions whether it's
regulations whether it's taxes
everything the government is doing is
trying to stop any kind of prosperity
any kind of sovereignty any kind of
liberty and freedom and trying to
benefit of course the corporate
billionaire class that has greatly
benefited from every one of those
policies so what we're seeing here is a
clash point but it's a clash point
that's not started by
pilots and stewardesses and kyrie irving
it's a reaction to something that may be
more methodical that may be done on
purpose in order to spur on more of an
economic destruction and calamity that
should be coming soon is it war
i mean some people say economic warfare
is right fifth generational warfare
target supply lines crush them and then
what have we seen over the past few
decades
one of the biggest problems that one of
the biggest weaknesses we face as a
country is capital incentives
you find a high powerful a powerful
individual or a high-powered company and
then you can easily offer them money to
guide them in the direction you want
see the thing about the chinese
communist party and the authoritarians
is that they're ideologically driven and
authoritarian so their incentives are
all based on whether i'm told to do it
or the tribe wants it in the united
states there could be a company and all
you gotta do is chip one one one step at
a time here's here's some money do this
here's some money do that and eventually
you can steer them in in the wrong
direction for example
if a bunch of contributions are coming
in to politicians who are advocating for
sending our manufacturing overseas and
then all of a sudden the middle class
gets gutted which has happened
the center will not hold there's no
center left our politicians have
literally gutted us and it was easy
easily easy to exploit them into doing
it
yeah look we see what's going on with
swalwell and fangfeng you know dianne
feinstein and her driver we saw mike
pompeo come out and say that there is
you know these these uh china the
chinese have infiltrated this every
level oh yeah so i'm wondering if we're
seeing all these shortages and all this
bad policy simply because there's this
is a means of war they play the long
game like the chinese like i mean they
know like they think in decades and
centuries well we're thinking about the
next election cycle like that we don't
think that further passed and so like
that was i know that's kind of one thing
you want to talk about but that was my
you know that whole area asia pacific
was mine and also you know jack bosovic
was one of the intel guys at my unit
that's how we became friends oh wow yeah
that was like that was our connection
that's like kind of eventually found my
way now i'm here like a few years later
which is crazy but yeah it's uh well
that was our big focus that side of the
world was china so and i did a couple
staff jobs i was in admiral staff and um
i drafted tiny little parts of the war
plans for
china if anything with taiwan were to
happen or south china sea and also a
separate war plan for north korea so you
know obviously i didn't write the whole
thing i wrote a little part of it it's a
huge huge document and it goes through
admirals and generals in this massive
process but uh one of the things with
the whole china thing is is on the
military side it's like
it's scary but that's the thing that's
not where this war is being fought it's
economic it's informational you know
that's where the real war is going to
fight you know the future it's fourth
and fifth generation it absolutely is i
would anticipate limited war though
unfortunately this could be something
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
tim youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you